what we're going to do in this video is
at least to get you a little bit
familiar with a bunch of forms that
you're likely to see when you get a job
and I'm not going to go into deep detail
on each of these forms but just to give
you some basic familiarity so that you
aren't caught unaware when you actually
have to fill these out yourself
so the first form that you're going to
see when you get a job as an employee
and I'll talk a little bit about being
an employee versus being a contractor
but if you're going to go work for wages
and you're going to get benefits then
you are an employee and this right over
here is a form I9 employment eligibility
verification and this is just to make
sure that you are qualified to work in
this country so you have some just basic
personal information up here and then
you say whether you're a citizen a
non-citizen national of the United
States a lawful permanent resident it's
or an alien authorized to work
etc etc so that's the whole reason for
this form now another form that you are
going to fill out if you are starting a
job as an employee is a W-4 employees
withholding certificate and this is to
let the employer know on every paycheck
you get how much should be with held and
sent to the IRS so we talk about this in
other videos but every time you get paid
your employer is going to set aside some
money and essentially pay your taxes and
at the end of the year when you do your
taxes you're going to make sure that the
right amount was paid if your employer
withheld more than they needed to you'll
get a refund you'll get some money back
and if the employer did not withhold
enough then you are going to have to pay
some extra taxes so once again you just
have your personal information up here
and then they ask some things about
deduct about dependents I should say and
other things at the bottom of this let
me actually just go down so that you can
see it you just sign that this is valid
so it shouldn't take you too much time
to fill it out but it does it ha it can
impact how much is actually withheld on
each pay cycle now as you go into a new
calendar year so let's say we're going
from 2023 to 2024 you usually in the
beginning of the new calendar year
you'll get a W-2 and this is very
important for actually filling out your
taxes so this is essentially a summary
that you get from your employer so the
previous two I just showed you fill it
out when you start a job but then in the
new calendar year you get this from the
employer and it's really important for
filling out your taxes because when you
fill out your taxes you can put in these
numbers of well what were your total
wages tips and other compensation how
much was withheld and remember that with
how much was withheld could be
influenced by that W4 how much would is
how much of this right over here is the
Social Security wages so the wages that
could be used to calculate how much
security Social Security tax is withheld
and it goes on and on and on trust me
you want this form in fact you need this
form in most cases around when you are
actually filling your taxes and it's
interesting to look at because it's an
interesting summary for what happened in
that previous year
now everything I just talked about is if
you are an employee there might be
situations where you are a contractor a
contractor is also someone who does
something for a company but an employee
is someone where you're getting wages
you're getting regular wages for certain
expectations that you're maybe you're
going to show up for a certain number of
hours or do certain types of regular
work you typically will get benefits for
that while a contractor is in some ways
operating at a higher level hey you're
going to build this for me and I'm going
to pay you but you're not an employee
you might do it only for a certain
amount of time or we the company can't
decide when and how you do your work as
long as you get it done by a certain
date and so for contractors you might
see a form like this and this is really
so that the company that is hiring the
contractor can get a taxpayer
identification number now you might be
wondering what is a taxpayer
identification number well in many cases
if you're just an individual contractor
it might be your social security number
but there's other situations I won't go
into all of the details there so the big
takeaway
especially when you're starting to
engage with the company especially as an
employee and we just talked a little bit
about as a contractor you're going to
have to fill out all these forms don't
be intimidated by it most of them just
require you to fill out some personal
information it's good to know what that
form is for and then you typically sign
at the bottom but hopefully now you're
going to go in a little bit more
prepared